you think of wild card like rock
celebrity like if there's ever been a
time to come in and win like this is a
good time to do it one of these guys
that's got a couple hundred million
followers on instagram twitter they come
and use that card i think elon musk in
the future is a candidate for president
he's not born here though uh-huh born in
southwest that's true actually you're
right that's that is the restriction
you're right but but that he's going to
be a major player yeah well he is now
but i mean
um but in our political system
you're saying an outsider with a major
massive following and a ton of money
like mark cuban will he run in in 2024
like impossible i mean he'd like to be
president
he saw trump do it he's a democrat uh
you know he's got a social image that
he's building uh could he win the
nomination i don't think so i think the
problem on the democratic side is it's
going to be a leftist candidate for
president and wow
and i'm going to come that we're going
to have a leftist candidate
i think that's what's going to emerge
from the democratic party especially if
what happens in 22 it's going to hurt
them
oh they're going to get trounced if
that's the direction
look at what they're doing they're
doubling down i'm moving left i'm
putting pressure on biden right now on
student debt soon if he does student
debt
i mean it's it's i mean it's it's really
stupid from a political standpoint but
from the left standpoint uh you know
they they like what it stands for but if
he does the student debt issue what's
going to happen
he's not going to get he's not going to
pump up turnoff
in an
off-year cycle among young people i mean
he may go from 37 to 45 percent voting
for democrats but you know what the
number one issue is for for people in 19
18 to 29 right now
inflation
the economy
and jobs
and so
do you think
that for giving the debt for a segment
of the 18 to 29 because what happens all
the people aren't going to college right
what happens to the people who are
starting college next year
what about my debt
you know these are the kinds of issues
that you know affect who's going to turn
out and how they're going to turn out
what about the guys who paid for their
debt yeah like me i paid off my okay
yeah there you go i mean the point is
the left doesn't care that's a big
that's a big vote
if you're able to get you know all these
folks college debt to be
forgiven you know what loyalty you'll
get from them because that that keeps a
lot of people but they're not even a
majority of the segment of the 18 to 20.
not at all they're not no and what
what's going to happen what does it do
to inflation
which is the number one issue for that
voter bloc well actually for every voter
block but for that voter block you know
it's going to make it worse
and so all of a sudden now you're you're
rewarding people who a small segment who
got college debt
and you're punishing
everyone in that time in the country
with inflation
which is the number one issue
the but the left only cares about where
they're going to be in january of 2023.
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]